all right now look this comes the end of
the whole interview but there's one
question there's an elephant in the room
i gotta ask has anyone ever asked i'm
sure
when you were gonna get married to julia
roberts i know this is old hat
this is 30 years old 30 plus 30 years
old so who gives a at this point
right it's been that long i mean you
were kids then
supposedly you had a thing with julia
roberts
you took off to somewhere where'd you go
well i mean that was all
that was all the the press i mean the
fact was from my sister ireland
yeah i went to ireland ireland uh yeah
i was gonna say have you guys ever
talked about it was it always the other
yeah
you have yeah we talked yeah sure yeah
well because
go ahead go ahead james no we talked
about we hadn't seen each other
um we hadn't seen each other for over 20
years
and then we contacted i don't know if it
was that long but yeah
sure it was man yeah we probably i think
we hooked up again in
2009 or two thousand ten
and i hadn't seen in nine yeah over
twenty for that
well so a long time but yes we had
talked about it
look the thing is is that she's not here
so
right in this room so i'd feel strange
talking about what she told me
or what she told kiefer because she
could speak for herself right
but the large stuff about the press and
being invited to the wedding and then
taking off with the bride and all that
that's all you know i
mean i i don't
keep her specific relationship and what
they were at the time that's theirs i
mean he can speak but ultimately there
was a thing in uh
rolling stone and kiefer said something
and then you called kiefer
right well i was making a joke about the
country song
and someone had asked me a question
about jason i said well i mean you know
i lost my pickup of my dog and my best
friend and i
miss my best friend you know and so
look the press can make whatever it does
and
and that was a difficult time for me and
i think it was an uncomfortable time for
both of them
um but look honestly the truth
where i'm coming from
you fall in love you fall in love
there's nothing you can do about that
and
she's an extraordinary person and he is
too and
and you know
timing is what it is and you know
everybody moves on from that
well the maturity though because i mean
most people could never you know get
over something like that or they would
hold grudges or whatever but you guys
had a bond i guess
i don't know i mean george harrison and
eric were best friends till the
bitter end you know but it wasn't it you
know
it it wasn't to and it wasn't that by
the way right so that's right
i figure if they can deal with what they
thought we could i think
when we when i saw him again whenever
that was 12 years ago or whatever it
sort of it was a few words of this and
that it was more of a laugh and a toast
and i've said in the press before
they've both been subsequently married
since
a couple times i think they're both very
happy in their lives
and what lasted after all that is me and
kiefer is
you know 35 year buddies